pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé le 14
juillet 1789 il faut revenir à ce
qu'était dans la pratique la prison de
la bastille cette forteresse du faubourg
s de paris a été édifiée au moyen âge
pour des raisons d'abord militaire plus
tard on l'a transformée en prison d'état
c'est ici qu'ont enfermer les
prisonniers personnel du roi pourquoi
personnel parce que le souverain les a
signé ici de son propre chef sans aucun
procès au seul nom de son droit de faire
justice les actes en vertu desquels les
prisonniers du roi était conduisent à la
bastille s'appelait des lettres de
cachet
claude quétel s'est penché sur cette
forme de justice à nos yeux bien
arbitraire la bastille fonctionne sur un
système très secret on ne sait pas qui y
est et on ne sait pas pourquoi
du coup on soupçonne les pires choses et
quand l'heure certains linguet publie en
1783 ses mémoires sur la bastille pour
avoir été lui-même embastillé le livre
un succès extraordinaire parce que on ya
enfin on va en savoir plus sur ce qui se
passe à la bastille
[Musique]
simon langue est un ancien avocat devenu
chroniqueur sait de quoi il parle
louis saez vient de l'envoyer passé deux
ans sous les verrous pour avoir écrit
des articles un peu trop polémique dans
son pamphlet il dénonce les conditions
de détention à la bastille où il affirme
avoir souffert le martyr
plus il se plaint plus on s'aperçoit
qu'en fait le régime des prix d'inde à
bastille est plutôt meilleur que celui
des prisonniers qu'on peut trouver
ailleurs la bastille prison du roi
tombeau où on est en dessous vie vivant
où il n'y a que des victimes de la
vindicte royal les lettres de cachet en
blanc les tortues la bastille les
exécutions sommaires à la bastille tout
ça rien de tout ça n'existe on est sous
l'oeil du roi le roi se fait rendre
compte très exactement de ce qui se
passe à la bastide l'état d'esprit des
prisonniers donc on peut être très
choyés à la bastille assez choyés à la
bastille on mange très très bien ou à
l'ordinaire qui est déjà un peu moins
bien
même si le vin de la bastille est très
correct en effet si leurs conditions le
permettaient les prisonniers de la
bastille pouvait demander à recevoir des
visites à faire venir leurs meubles
leurs domestiques voire leurs épouses
linguère raconte tout ça avec avec plein
de détails tout à fait intéressant par
exemple il s'insurge que on lui laisse
pas se couper lui-même les ongles et
alors on voit comment effectivement il
ya un barbier il suffit qu'on l'appelle
il vous coupe les cheveux il vous coupe
les ongles
donc on a un tas de détails sur la vie
quotidienne tous les détenus de cette
forteresse jouissent est il du même
traitement pour répondre à cette
question il faut aller consulter les
archives de la bastille aujourd'hui
conservée à la bibliothèque de l'arsenal
c'est ce que fait inlassablement depuis
plus de 30 ans l'historienne arlette
farge dont le travail s'apparente à
celui d'un archéologue car ces archives
sont lacunaires
certaines sont même très abîmé le 14
juillet 1789 des tas de documents ont
été précipités du haut des tours de la
bastille est traîné dans la boue des
fossés c'est très précieux
c'est très émouvant de penser qu'il ya
là de lamu de du 14 juillet 1789 qui
restait jusque là ça ne se montre que
dans des expositions ou que dans des
moments très rares de l'avis de cette
bibliothèque
ce sont vraiment des témoignages
extrêmement fort d'avoir centre entre
ses mains parce que c'est paillard à la
bastille pour peu que l'on soit noble ou
fortunés l'on bénéficie d'un régime
plutôt doux bien éloignée en tout cas
des souffrances endurées d'ordinaire
dans les prisons d'état mais c'est une
douceur soumise à conditions comme le
révèlent les archives les prisonniers de
la bastille ne sont pas tous logés à la
même enseigne
[Musique]
longtemps pensé que la bastille ne
contenait que des aristocrates c'est
parce que notre histoire traditionnelle
faisait davantage attention aux
histoires des aristocrates de cours des
maîtresses et favorite et et des récits
voilà qui sont le charme des légendes et
qui ont rien à voir avec la réalité
historique parce que en fait c'est autre
partie de la population sont des gens
qui n'ont pas l'argent et qui donc ont
un traitement extrêmement dur certains
sont enchaînés par les pieds sont dans
l'humidité on les appelle les pailles
eux parce qu'ils n'ont qu'une paille
pour se coucher qui échangent et que
tous les mois donc c'est sale répugnons
plein de microbes y attrape des maladies
ils ne mangent que du pain
je présente la bastille comme comme un
hôtel extrêmement confortable la table
est soigné c'est vrai mais le logement
est quand même assez triste et assez
sordide parce que on n'a pas rénové
pratiquement il ya pas eu de travaux
depuis la fin du moyen âge
donc on imagine assez bien à quoi
peuvent ressembler ce qu'on appelle
pompeusement les chambres de la bastille
le cas du prisonnier taurin par exemple
a de quoi effrayer ce simple domestique
a été enfermé vingt ans durant dans un
cachot simplement parce qu'il avait rêvé
une nuit qu'il menaçait le roi et qu'il
avait eu l'imprudence le lendemain de
s'en vanter de bonnes âmes l'ont dénoncé
aux autorités
on a ici tout le dossier
il ment ce qu'il a écrit des longues
longues lettres qui s'adresse à dieu qui
s'adresse aux voir pour dire qu'il veut
sortir parce que ils pensent à l'honneur
de son père et à la tristesse de son
père et puis petit à petit tout devient
fou son écriture reste sage
mais ce qu'il écrit est fou il mourra
dans une folie un délire de persécution
très très intenses et les led sont
tragiques
comment comment le roi pouvait-il se
sentir menacé par le rêve d'un de ces
sujets je crois que ça résume vraiment
le ce qu'était ce qu'a pu être la
bastille et ce pour quoi on s'est
révoltés contre la bastille sous louis
saez la bastille est devenu dans
l'imaginaire du peuple un objet de
terreur et de détestations est d'autant
plus qu'elle obscurcit le paysage
parisien et bouchent l'horizon du
faubourg saint-antoine
avec ses huit grosses tours tellement
hot tellement massive la colère du
peuple
elle s'exprime contre les symboles ou
des instruments visible versailles c'est
très loin
quel est l'instrument visible dans le
quartier c'est la bastille donc on
s'amassent autour de la bastide parce
qu'on estime qu'on est menacée par les
canons ni aux endroits sur ses canons
qui sont braqués sur le quartier énerve
des habitants qui sont déjà énervé au
départ et donc il y a quand même
une volonté générale d'en découdre quand
même délégation de l'hôtel de ville
cette ville allez-vous bac de rangement
canaux
[Applaudissements]
quand les délégués de l'hôtel de ville
viennent lui demander déjà d'enlever les
canaux launay diva oui bien sûr je veux
bien faire retirer les canons si ça peut
calmer les choses
alors on retire les canons mais les gens
en bas de la bastille eux ils croient
que les soldats retire les canons pour
les charges et donc en fait au lieu de
se dire ah bah tiens c'est un signe de
bonne volonté disent attention attention
on va charger les canons on va nous
tirer dessus à mitraille il croit que la
halle au signal de la répression est
arrivé et c'est à ce moment là que vient
la foulée dans un mouvement de foule
secret et on décide de forcer la porte
pour pour rentrer de force dans la
bastide la prise de la bastille est
l'événement qui a fait capituler le roi
le 14 juillet est bien le point de
départ véritable de la révolution les
contemporains ne s'y trompe pas dès le
un entrepreneur du nom de palois prend
en main la démolition de la forteresse
et la commercialisation de toutes sortes
d'objets représentant l'épopée des
parisiens objets fabriqués à partir des
matériaux de la bastille les vestiges de
la forteresse se muant reliques
[Musique]